>> Chris: MOHAMED EL-ERIAN IS
AN INFLUENTIAL VOICE IN THE
FINANCIAL WORLD.
IN HE LED PIMCO FOR YEARS
RUNNING THE WORLD’S LARGEST BOND
FUND.
AND NOW HE IS THE CHIEF ECONOMIC
ADVISOR RED AT ALLIANZ.
I SAT DOWN WITH HIM ON FRIDAY.
IN MR. EL-ERIAN, UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS JUST CAME IN UNDER
3 MILLION AND SAID WOW THAT IS A
TOUGH NUMBER, IT IS AN
INDICATION THAT THE ECONOMY
IS STARTING TO COME BACK.
HERE HE IS.
>> THE FACT THAT WE CAME IN
UNDER 3 MILLION SUGGEST THAT THE
TURNING ON OF THE ECONOMY IS
BEGINNING TO SHOW UP WITH THE
DATA SO WHAT WE EXPECT HIS
CLAIMS WILL CONTINUE TO DECLINE
AS THE ECONOMY TURNS BACK.
>> Chris: DO YOU SEE THE JOBS
PICTURE GETTING BRIGHTER RIGHT
NOW?
>> IT WILL GET BRIGHTER IN THE
SENSE IT WILL GET AT A SLOWER
RATE, BUT WE SHOULD NOT FORGET
HOW BAD THIS PICTURE IS.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL 3 MILLION,
THAT IS 36 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
SIGNED UP ON JOBLESS CLAIMS IN
EIGHT WEEKS.
THAT’S ONE QUARTER OF OUR LABOR
FORCE, SO IT’S AN ENORMOUS SHOCK
SHOCK.
>> Chris: SO THE CONSISTENT
FORECAST FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IS
OF A SHARP, STEEP, QUICK
DOWNTURN TO BE FOLLOWED IN A V
SHAPE BY A SHARP, QUICK REBOUND.
HERE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THAT
THIS WEEK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO WELL IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER AND WITH ALL
OF THE STIMULUS AND ALL THE
THINGS WE’VE DONE I’M GOING TO
HAVE ONE OF THE BEST ECONOMIC
YEARS WE NEVER HAD.
>> Chris: DO YOU SEE A
V-SHAPED RECOVERY AS THE
WHITE HOUSE IS PREDICTING THAT
THE ECONOMY IS GOING TO COME
BACK AS QUICKLY AND AS SHARPLY
AS IT WENT DOWN?
>> I SURE HOPE SO, BUT I THINK
IT’S UNCERTAIN, AND IT’S
UNCERTAIN BECAUSE BOTH THE
JOURNEY TO NEXT YEAR AND WHAT
NEXT YEAR LOOKS LIKE IS
UNCERTAIN.
IN THE RATHER THAN THINK OF
LETTERS, THINK OF A PENDULUM.
WE WERE OPERATING IN A NORMAL
WORLD AND SEE WHEN I DO FIND IT.
WE THEN SWUNG ALL THE WAY ON THE
OTHER SIDE TO A LOCKDOWN AND NOW
GOING TO SWING BACK AND FORTH
TRYING TO FIND WHERE EQUILIBRIUM
IS.
THINK OF A PENDULUM SWINGING,
AND WE DON’T KNOW THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE SWINGS, AND WE DON’T KNOW
THE DURATION OF THE SWING FOR
THE SETTLING POINT, SO IT REALLY
IS AN UNCERTAIN OUTLOOK.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THAT BECAUSE YOU SAY PEOPLE ARE
BEING NAIVE ABOUT HOW EASY AND
QUICK IT IS GOING TO BE TO
REOPEN THE ECONOMY AND WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH HEALTH FACTORS AND
ECONOMIC FACTORS AND EVEN
BEHAVIORAL FACTORS.
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU MEAN BOTH IN
TERMS OF THIS COUNTRY AND
GLOBALLY AND IN REOPENING THE
ECONOMY.
>> THIS IS THE BIGGEST SHOCK
WE’VE HAD FOR GENERATIONS AND IT
RAISES THREE ISSUES.
ONE IS THE MAIN REASON FOR THE
SHOCK’S HEALTH.
IT’S GOING TO BE A LONG TIME
UNTIL YOU AND I TRUST EACH
OTHER.
IT’S WHAT ERIC SCHMIDT CALLS THE
INFORMATION FAILURE.
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
CONVINCE YOU I’M HEALTHY UNTIL
WE GET A VACCINE.
SO THE HEALTH ISSUE DOESN’T GET
RESOLVED OVERNIGHT.
SECONDLY, YOU HAVE SHAKEN
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE, SHAKEN
BEHAVIORS.
OUR ECONOMY IS IN WIRED FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING, SO WE WILL
HAVE TO DISCOVER HOW TO DO THAT.
AND BUSINESSES, IT IS NOT CLEAR
HOW YOU RESTART A BUSINESS WHEN
DIFFERENT STATES ARE DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS AND WHEN
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES WILL DO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT’S WE HAVE THESE MASSIVE
UNCERTAINTIES ALL IN PLAY AT THE
SAME TIME, AND IT IS VERY HARD
TO SAY EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE
RESOLVED OVERNIGHT.
I THINK WE SHOULD BUCKLE OUR
SEAT BELT AS IT WILL GET BUMPY
STILL.
>> Chris: THERE WAS ANOTHER
UNCERTAINTY AND DEBATE AND THAT
IS OVER WHAT TO DO IN WASHINGTON
NEXT.
DEMOCRATS WON A HUGE STIMULUS
BILL, REPUBLICANS SAY LET’S TAKE
A PAUSE AND SEE HOW THE MONEY
SIPHONS THROUGH THE ECONOMY
THAT’S BEEN APPROVED SO FAR, AND
THIS WEEK, YOU HAVE
FEDERAL RESERVE CHAIRMAN
JEROME POWELL SAY THAT THIS HAS
BEEN A REAL ECONOMIC SHOCK, AND
WE DO NEED MORE STIMULUS.
HERE HE IS ON THAT.
>> THE ECONOMIC RESPONSE HAS
BEEN BOTH TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATELY LARGE.
MAY NOT BE THE FINAL CHAPTER.
GIVEN THAT THE PATH AHEAD IS
BOTH HIGHLY UNCERTAIN AND
SUBJECT TO SIGNIFICANT DOWNSIDE
RISKS.
>> Chris: DO YOU THINK WE NEED
MORE GOVERNMENT STIMULUS?
AND IF SO, HOW MUCH, AND HOW
QUICKLY?
>> SO FAR, WE HAVEN’T HAD
GOVERNMENT STIMULUS.
WE HAVE HAD GOVERNMENT RELIEF.
AND IT’S A GOOD THING WE HAVE IT
AND IT’S A GOOD THING THAT
WASHINGTON REACTED $5 TRILLION
AWAY FROM REACTION BECAUSE
DESPITE THAT, THIS WEEK ALSO
GAVE US NOT JUST HORRIBLE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBER BUT THE
WORST INDUSTRIAL COLLAPSE IN A
CENTURY IN THE WORST RETAIL
COLLAPSE ON RECORD.
SO WE ARE HURTING AND THANK GOD
THAT WASHINGTON HAS ACTED.
WHAT’S IMPORTANT NOW IS NOT TO
LOSE SIGHT OF THE SECOND PHASE.
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
DEPRESSION ON A U.S. DEPRESSION,
THIS IS ABOUT SECURING THE PEACE
MAKING SURE THAT WE EMERGE FROM
THIS ALSO STRONG.
SO THE NEXT STAGE HAS TO ALSO
FOCUS ON KEY ISSUES LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE, RETAILING AND A
RETOOLING.
A SAFETY NETS, THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE CRITICAL IF WE ARE
TO BOUNCE BACK IN A SUSTAINABLE
MANNER, OTHERWISE WE WILL GET
STUCK WITH REALLY MEDIOCRE
GROWTH AND GREATER SOCIAL
TENSIONS.
>> Chris: AND THEN, THERE ARE
THE FINANCIAL MARKETS WHICH I
THINK SURPRISED A LOT OF PEOPLE
BY REMAINING SURPRISINGLY
STRONG.
IN FACT, THE MARKETS ARE UP
ABOUT 25% FROM THEIR BOTTOM IN
LATE MARCH.
YOU SAY THAT THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS ARE OF ONE UNIVERSE, AND
THE REAL ECONOMY IS IN THE
DIFFERENT UNIVERSE.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> THEY ARE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
THINGS.
SO WONDERING WHERE YOU AND WE GO
BACK TO WORK.
WHEN THE STORES OPEN AGAIN?
WE FEEL VERY BIG DISRUPTIONS FOR
EVERYDAY LIFE.
IN THE IS SAYING THAT’S FINE BUT
THAT IS ALL SHORT-TERM.
IN WE LOOK TO THE LONG TERM.
WHEN WE SEE THEY ARE TOO
OPTIMISTIC BUT LET ME EXPLAIN
WHAT WE SEE.
FIRST, GOING TO BET THAT THEY
COME BACK QUICKLY.
AND IF YOU COME BACK QUICKLY,
THEN LOOKING THROUGH THE PHRASE
I HEAR THE MOST, THIS AWFUL
PERIOD IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
BUT THEY HAVE A SECOND WIN.
WE GET THAT WRONG, IT DOESN’T
MATTER BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL RESERVE IS BUYING ASSETS
THAT WE NEVER IMAGINED IT WOULD
BUY.
SO THERE IS THIS SENSE OF
COMFORT THAT YOU GET TO WIN
WHATEVER THEY OUTLOOK.
I THINK IT IS TOO OPTIMISTIC,
BUT MARKETS DO WHAT THEY DO.
>> Chris: I WAS GOING TO ASK
YOU, DO YOU THINK THE MARKETS IS
ONE OF THE GREAT INVESTORS, DO
YOU THINK THE MARKETS ARE GOING
TO STAY AS STRONG AS THEY ARE
RIGHT NOW, OR DO YOU THINK AT
SOME POINT, THE TWO UNIVERSES
ARE GOING TO COLLIDE AND REALITY
WILL RUN THROUGH?
>> MOST OF US WHO THINK
FUNDAMENTALS ARE IMPORTANT, THAT
ULTIMATELY YOU ARE BETTING ON
COMPANY’S PROFITABILITY AND
BEDDING ON THE LIABILITY OF A
SYSTEM ARE CAUTIOUS HERE.
AND WE HAVE SEVERAL WARNINGS
FROM REALLY RESPECTED INVESTORS.
IN THOSE THAT SAY WE ARE BETTING
ON SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
WE ARE BETTING ON THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
I PERSONALLY THINK IT’S EASIER
TO MAKE A RELATIVE CALL BETWEEN
DIFFERENT COMPANIES.
I GET NERVOUS BETTING ON THE
OVERALL LEVEL OF THE MARKET
RIGHT HERE.
>> Chris: MOHAMED EL-ERIAN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IS ALWAYS FASCINATING TO TALK TO
YOU AND TO GET A LITTLE DOSE OF